-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Let's get to some news,
you guys.
Last night, President Biden
did a rare sit-down interview
on "60 Minutes."
I don't know if you saw this.
And he made a pretty big
announcement.
In case you missed it,
here it is.
-Is the pandemic over?
-The pandemic is over.
We still have a problem
with COVID.
We're still doing
a lot of work on it.
It's --
But the pandemic is over.
[ Laughter ]
-It's kind of huge news to
mention so casually, you know?
I wasn't expecting the end of a
two-and-a-half-year nightmare
to be announced on the floor
of the Detroit Auto Show.
It's like hearing,
"I had a good day.
Went for a run, ate breakfast,
the baby was born, you know."
[ Laughter ]
Apparently Biden's comment was
not part of his planned remarks
and caught several of his own
health officials by surprise.
Dr. Fauci was like, "Oh, God.
it's 2020 all over again.
Oh, my God."
For the rest of the interview,
whenever Biden
answered a question,
a staffer quickly revved
a car engine.
He's like, "That's right. We're
going to go to war with Ch--"
[ Engine revs, tires screech ]
"We're gonna support Tai--"
Later in the interview, Biden,
though, was asked about his age.
Watch this.
-Mr. President, you are
the oldest president ever.
-Pretty good shape, huh?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-He handled it pretty well,
yeah.
Although, I will say it got
a little dicey after that.
Take a look at this.
-How would you say
your mental focus is?
-Oh, it's focused.
[ Laughs ]
I say -- I think it's --
I -- I haven't -- Look.
You think I would tell you
if I knew exactly?
Of course
I'm not going to tell you.
So I -- Look.
This is a process.
And the proof of the pudding's
in the eating.
I mean, don't -- don't -- don't.
My point is, it takes time.
How's an old guy do that?
I no more think of myself
as being as old as I am
than a fly.
-What do you mean?
-No.
-No, man. Yo, yo, yo. Yo!
-That's edited, right?
-No.
-Alright. Thank you.
-That's a joke.
-No, that's not real.
-Oh God.
[ Laughter ]
-Props to our editors there.
Well, I saw that this weekend
former president Trump
spoke at a rally in Ohio,
and at one point
during his speech,
music started playing,
and his supporters reacted
in a pretty strange way.
Check this out.
-And a Department of Justice
that refuses to investigate
egregious acts...
[ Grand, sweeping music plays ]
...of voting irregularities
and fraud.
And we have a president
who is cognitively impaired
and in no condition
to lead our country.
-Not creepy at all.
Then Trump was like,
"And now to sacrifice
the first-born sons.
Come up here, Don Jr."
[ Laughter ]
What was going on?
Meanwhile, Trump just returned
to Mar-a-lago
for the first time
since the FBI search,
and he's complaining
that FBI agents
didn't even take off their shoes
before going into his bedroom.
Yeah, for some reason,
the agents weren't like,
"FBI! This is a raid!"
[ Laughter ]
"Should have wore Velcro."
Of course, everyone is talking
about this today --
leaders, dignitaries,
and politicians
from around the world
gathered in London
for the funeral
of Queen Elizabeth.
Meanwhile, Trump showed up
at a Burger King
and said,
"Sorry for your loss."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Two whoppers.
French fries. Diet Coke."
[ Applause ]
In observance for the funeral,
flights in and out of
London's Heathrow Airport
were canceled or delayed.
LaGuardia heard that
and was like,
"Uh, that's also why our
flights are, uh..."
[ Clears throat ]
"Out of respect, of course.
We're gonna be respecting
till, like,
around New Year's, probably.
That's what was...
We'll continue our respect.
Yeah."
Some entertainment news --
we're just one month away
from the release
of Taylor Swift's
10th studio album, "Midnights."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And fans are already finding
all kinds of secret messages
about the album
in her social-media posts.
-Oh, man, all that stuff is just
conspiracy theories, though.
-Uh, I don't know, Tariq.
The clues are --
The clues are everywhere.
-What clues?
-Okay, so, Taylor made
a surprise announcement
at this year's VMAs
that her 10th studio album
was gonna be called "Midnights"
and it would come out
at midnight on October 21st.
You follow?
-Uh...
-So, 13 is Taylor's
favorite number,
and "Midnights" is gonna have
13 tracks on it,
but nobody knows
what the songs are called yet.
On all the album art
she's shared so far,
all the songs have fake titles
like "Track One," "Track Two,"
that kind of thing.
-And that means...?
-But when she posted a video
announcing all of
the limited-edition vinyls,
the names of the songs were
all blurred out on the covers,
so you can tell the songs
won't actually be called
"Track One," "Track Two."
And that was on September 1st.
Then on September 16th,
she posted another video
revealing
that if you line up the backs of
all the special-edition vinyls
with the regular-edition one,
it makes a clock.
Midnight is a time on a clock.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay. Okay, well, I guess --
-Yeah, but here --
here's where
it gets interesting.
In Taylor's entire discography,
she's only sung the word
"midnight" in six songs.
She sings it in "Style"
off of "1989,"
"You Are in Love" off of "1989,"
"New Year's Day"
off of "Reputation,"
"The Last Great American
Dynasty" off "Folklore,"
"Happiness" off of "Evermore,"
and, of course,
in "22 (Taylor's Version)"
off "Red (Taylor's Version)."
[ Laughter ]
And that's not even
the crazy part.
'Cause it also turns out
she's sung the phrase
"middle of the night"
in seven songs
throughout her discography.
She sings it in "...Ready
For It?" off "Reputation,"
"Daylight" off of "Lover,"
"You Belong with Me
(Taylor's Version)"
off of
"Fearless (Taylor's Version),"
"Untouchable
(Taylor's Version),"
off of "Fearless
"All Too Well (10 Minute
Version) (Taylor's Version)"
off of "Red (Taylor's Version),"
"Better Man
(Taylor's Version)"
off of "Red (Taylor's Version),"
and "Nothing New
(feat. Phoebe Bridgers)
(Taylor's version)"
off of "Red (Taylor's Version)."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What are you even saying?!
-Six "midnights" plus seven
"middle of the nights"
equal...13.
13 is Taylor's favorite number.
That's how many songs
are on "Midnights."
Taylor's a genius!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what.
You get it now?
-Yeah, I get it.
Happy birthday.
-Thank you. I appreciate it.
Well, this is going viral.
Guys, an 80-year-old
state Senate candidate in Utah
named Linda Paulson
is going viral
because of a new campaign video
that she just released.
Can we see this, please?
♪♪
-Oh, no.
-♪ Hey, Utah District 12,
listen up right here ♪
♪ There's a new name
on the ballot ♪
♪ For the Senate this year ♪
♪ My name is Linda Paulson,
Republican and awesome ♪
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-At that point, the Tupac
hologram unplugged itself.
[ Laughter ]
It's like if "Hamilton"
was written by Mike Pence.
Doesn't it kind of...?
And finally, guys, do you
ever see a photo in the news
and think that headline
should be different?
Well, we'll take care
of that right now.
It's time for "News and
Improved." Here we go.
-♪ News and Improved ♪
-For example, check out --
check out this first photo here.
The original headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
The next headline was...
Headline could have been...
"No one's getting fired."
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ]
"Oh, yeah. This was back..."
-"I coulda.
I didn't. But I coulda."
-"I didn't, but I coulda."
"Are you sure?"
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Wow!
That's a headline.
-Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
[ Applause ]
-And finally,
this headline was...
Headline could have been...
It's a busy time
in New York City because leaders
from all around the world
are in town
for the U.N. General Assembly.
Yeah.
And I just want to say
on behalf of all New Yorkers,
this could have been a Zoom.
[ Laughter ]
Have we learned nothing?
[ Applause ]
Two and a half hours
to go three blocks?
What are we doing, people?
Yeah, this is the first
in-person General Assembly
since the pandemic.
That's right.
For the last three years,
the U.N. has been home
to the world's largest
Spirit Halloween.
[ Laughter ]
Fun fact. Fun fact. Fun fact.
[ Applause ]
That's right.
Today leaders from 193 nations
flew into New York
on private jets
and drove into the U.N.
in huge motorcades
all with one shared goal --
to fight climate change.
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, I love when the U.N.
General Assembly is in session.
There's no greater joy than
watching the king of Norway
getting into a fight
with his Uber driver.
You know? It's just magic.
There's a magic spirit
in the air.
For several days,
there will be dozens of speeches
at the U.N.,
and the after-party --
Ron DeSantis is transporting
all the foreign leaders
to Martha's Vineyard.
-Aww.
-Isn't that nice?
That's nice. Very thoughtful.
[ Applause ]
Actually, tomorrow President
Biden will speak at the U.N.
He's part of the long lineup
of leaders from across the world
who will be making remarks.
Let's take a look at what
their speeches are about.
For instance, here's
the president of Portugal.
Yep, he's speaking about how
every dinner party he attends
turns into a murder mystery.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What?
-"I wouldn't know!"
Next up, here's the
president of South Korea.
He's speaking about
all the hot goss
from the "Don't Worry Darling"
press tour.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Next up,
here's the leader of Finland.
Yeah, he's speaking about
reacting to good news
by saying, "MmmmmMMMYESSS."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Next up,
here's the president of Brazil.
He's speaking about
how easy it is
to steel sashes
from Girl Scouts.
You go, "Well, that's --
It shouldn't be that easy."
It shouldn't be that easy.
Next up,
here's the leader of Germany.
He's speaking
about that time he spent
playing the dad
on "That '70s Show."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Lots of speeches.
Here's the president of Latvia.
He's speaking about mustaches
that age slower
than the rest of your head.
-Oh.
[ Applause ]
-Next up,
here's the president of Chile.
He's speaking about
looking more like
the president of
Royal Caribbean Cruise Lines.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally, here's Joe Biden.
He's speaking about
the Showcase Showdown
and getting your pet
spayed or neutered.
[ "Price is Right" theme plays ]
-Come on down!
♪♪
-Uh, did you guys
see this yesterday
at the Queen's funeral?
President Biden was there.
He was seated in the 14th row.
Well, former president Trump
noticed, and he said...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Yeah, at funerals, Trump demands
to be seated directly on top of
the coffin or he won't --
he won't show up.
[as Trump]
"I gotta be right there.
I don't care
if it's open or closed."
[ Laughter ]
-"Me!"
-Yeah, Biden was
in the 14th row.
Even worse, he got stuck behind
one of those royal guards
with the giant fuzzy hats.
He's like, "Alright.
Why even invite me? Come on."
But that wasn't all that Trump
had to say about
where Biden was seated.
He also said...
Biden was like, "He's right.
Whether it's funerals
or classified documents,
location is everything."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
"You're correct.
It is everything."
Well, people are
talking about this.
The chief operating officer
of Beyond Meat --
this is a real story --
was just arrested
for a really strange reason.
Check this out.
-The COO of Beyond Meat
is facing charges
for biting a man's nose after
a football game in Arkansas.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes!
-And in a blind taste test,
he said he couldn't tell
the difference between a nose
and a Beyond Meat nose.
-Wow.
-Can't even tell the difference.
Well, switching gears,
I heard that the latest
Gen Z fashion trend is wearing
jeans with the button undone.
-Ooh.
-Yeah, which means after
Thanksgiving dinner, every uncle
Is going to be like,
"Ohh. I look like
Gigi freaking Hadid over here!
What am I -- What am I doin'?!
Hey!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, today New York
Attorney General Letitia James
announced a lawsuit against
former president Trump
and his three adult children
for allegedly committing
widespread business fraud.
[ Audience oohs ]
You can tell Trump's worried
because he just asked
Ron DeSantis to fly him
somewhere random
in the middle of the night.
[ Laughter ]
Trump is being accused
of exaggerating
the value of his properties.
The attorney general
cited a few examples.
One of them being that Trump
said Mar-a-Lago is worth
$739 million, but it was only
appraised at $75 million.
[ Laughter ]
Trump was like,
"Technically, with all
the classified documents,
it is worth $739 million."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You took it out.
Yep, $739 million, almost
10 times the actual value.
Trump was going to put down
$740 million,
but he didn't want to
arouse suspicion.
[ Laughter ]
In response to the alleged
fraud, the State of New York
is now suing Trump
for $250 million.
Trump was like, "$250 million?
That's how much my fish tank
is appraised for."
[ Laughter ]
"Alright. Just take the tank."
Yes, Trump exaggerated the size
of his wealth,
his apartment,
and his properties.
It's the first time he's ever
lied about how big something is.
[ Laughter ]
Other than his inauguration
crowd,
his vote total,
and his night with
Stormy Daniels.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Take the fish tank.
Take the tank.
I hate to see it go."
Yep, the attorney general laid
out all the details of
Trump's alleged fraud, and then
she ended her press conference
by saying this.
-Claiming you have money
that you do not have
does not amount to
"The Art of the Deal."
It's the art of the steal.
-Ooh.
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Rimshot ]
That's a burn.
-Ooh.
-That's an accidentally locking
yourself in a tanning bed burn.
[ Laughter ]
"Help, help."
Some more big news from here
in New York.
This morning President Biden
addressed
the U.N. General assembly.
In his 30-minute speech,
Biden said we need peace
between Russia and Ukraine
in Europe
and also Rachel and Tino
on "The Bachelorette."
We need peace.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Biden spent a good portion
of his speech on Russia.
You can tell he was serious
because he was doing
that weird whisper thing.
[ Whispering ]
"That's why we do everything
[Normal voice]
to defeat Russia!"
I like that whisper thing
he does.
[ Whispering ] "We've been
trying to raise money
the whole time.
[ Normal voice ]
Building more bridges!"
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Russia, today
Vladimir Putin asked for 300,000
more troops in Ukraine,
and hinted that he hasn't ruled
out a nuclear response.
The only thing missing
from Putin's speech was
a cat for him
to pet the whole time.
[ Laughter ]
Even Kim Jong-un called.
He was like,
"Dude, you're scaring me.
What's up?"
[ Laughter ]
Let's switch gears.
Guys, I heard that YouTube's
"dislike" and "not interested"
buttons don't actually stop
the platform
from showing you
similar content.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, they're basically
the elevator door-close
buttons of the Internet.
[ Laughter ]
-He's coming, he's coming.
-Sorry.
I wish I could -- Ah!
Hi, how was your weekend?
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
Apparently "House of the Dragon"
is averaging 29 million viewers
per episode.
-Ooh!
-But now I think
all the networks are trying
to get in on the action.
I watched CNN this morning.
Wolf Blitzer looks
a little different.
Take a look.
Do you see what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
They're all trying to do it.
-It's crazy.
-Yeah.
Hey, guys, I read that American
Airlines just announced hackers
accessed
the personal information
of some of their customers.
But you can look at it this way.
When they use your credit card,
you still get miles.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-And finally, speaking of
airlines, I saw that Southwest
surprised a full flight with
ukulele lessons
on a trip
from California to Hawaii.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
The person in front of
the emergency exit was like,
"This counts, right?"
[ Laughter ]
They didn't just clap
when that plane landed.
They gave him
a standing ovation.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone is talking about this.
Last night,
former president Trump
was interviewed by Sean Hannity
on Fox News.
And when Hannity
brought up Trump's claim
that he declassified the
documents found at Mar-a-Lago,
Trump gave a very
interesting explanation.
Take a look at this.
-Is there a process?
What was your process
to declassify?
-There doesn't have to be
a process, as I understand it.
You know, there's different --
People say different things.
But, as I understand,
there doesn't have to be --
If you're the
President of the United States,
you can declassify just by
saying, "It's declassified,"
even by thinking about it.
-Hannity was like,
"Oh, I get it.
You're going to plead insanity.
Okay, now it's making sense."
Meanwhile, Ron DeSantis
was watching at home going,
"Well, I guess
we've got to start
printing those campaign posters.
Here we go."
I felt like he was this close to
using the word "abracadabra."
Did you --
When Trump was talking.
Trump also suggested
a pretty interesting theory
on why the FBI searched
his house in the first place.
Listen to this.
-Because of what they did,
the severity of the FBI
coming and raiding Mar-a-Lago,
were they looking for the
Hillary Clinton e-mails
that were deleted?
But they are around someplace.
Were they looking for the --
-Wait, wait.
You're not saying you had it.
-No, no.
They may be saying --
They may have thought
that it was in there.
-At that point, even QAnon
people were like,
"Okay, that conspiracy seems
a little nuts.
That's a little much for us."
You've got to give Trump
credit, though.
He knows how to say
something so crazy
that it actually makes
the last crazy thing he said
seem normal.
You know, right?
You know what I'm saying?
Trump had a lot to say about
the search of Mar-a-Lago,
including something
the FBI took from him.
Watch this.
-They took a lot.
I think they took my will.
I found out yesterday.
I said, "Where is it?"
-Am I in it?
-I think they took my will.
That could cause
a lot of problems.
-I know.
-The FBI was like, "Oh,
you mean the piece of paper
with the Sharpie treasure map?
Yeah, we did --"
A minute later,
Melania handed it back
and was like, "Sorry,
I was just checking something.
"We're all good."
Switching gears,
tonight on Amazon,
there was another
Thursday night football game.
And, apparently, Amazon -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Apparently, Amazon has a policy
not to show ads for alcohol,
which means there are no
beer commercials
during their football games.
Yeah. I don't know why
Amazon does that,
because drunk people
ordering stuff
on Amazon is
90% of their business.
Speaking of football,
there's so many games
to keep up with this weekend,
so I wanted to
take a moment to look at
this week's big matches
and take some picks.
It's time for "Tonight Show
Weekend Football Lock Box."
-♪ "Tonight Show Weekend
Football Lock Box" ♪
♪ "Tonight Show Weekend
-You're in the Lock Box.
Let's kick it off.
First up,
Jaguars versus Chargers.
I bought six
iPhone chargers this year
and zero jaguars.
Why? Because Chargers get lost
and Jags get locked.
Bills versus Dolphins.
Who likes bills?
Always coming in the mail, being
all like, "Where's my money?"
For the last time, I don't know.
Call it canned tuna,
because this one's all Dolphins.
Lock it.
Eagles versus Commanders.
Both proud, both symbols of
America, both bald.
But commanders can't lay eggs,
so advantage Eagles.
From the City of Brotherly Lock.
♪ B-B-B-Bengals and the Jets ♪
Elton John may be known to rock,
but Cincinnati's
the one brewing up a big batch
of chili and spaghetti
in a lock pot.
49ers versus Broncos.
It's the city by the bay against
the horse that eats the hay.
49ers pan for gold,
horses get locked in pens.
Easy Denver lock.
And, finally,
Lions versus Vikings.
For ball spiking,
lineman striking, fan sacking,
you just can't beat
the Detroit Lions.
Motor City lock.
That's all for
this week's Lock Box.
Happy watching.
I'll see you
in the DraftKings subreddit.
-♪ "Tonight Show Weekend
Football Lock Box" ♪
♪ "Tonight Show Weekend
-Some entertainment news.
A new "Star Wars" show, "Andor,"
just came out on Disney+.
It's getting great reviews.
And I saw that the show
introduces a new droid character
named B2EMO.
Can we take a look at B2EMO?
Honestly, he doesn't really
look that emo.
Can we see some clips of him
from the show?
-It's not a phase.
It's who I am.
Security confiscated
my wallet chain
at the My Chemical Romance show.
They're not cigarettes,
Dad, they're cloves.
And I'm 18, so leave me alone.
Has anyone seen my
"Nightmare Before Christmas"
beanie?
Just pick me up
at the mall at 10:00
and please don't embarrass me.
This whole star system
is bull[bleep]
-Oh, my God.
That was interesting.
Now I get it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-I get it.
Some more entertainment news.
Tomorrow, "Avatar"
will be re-released in theaters
all across the country.
The movie originally
came out in 2009.
That was a long time ago.
Higgins, do you remember
where you were when you --
back in 2009,
when you first saw "Avatar"?
-Oh, yeah, of course.
I was dancing to "Boom Boom Pow"
by the Black Eyed Peas...
-Uh-huh.
-...when my friend, the Octomom,
texted me the "Avatar" trailer
on my BlackBerry Storm.
And as a thank-you,
I poked her on Facebook.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yo, I still remember
where I was
when I found out about "Avatar."
I was hanging out with my BFFs,
Taylor Lautner and Susan Boyle.
And we were
ghost-riding the whip
when Susan starts telling me
how good "Avatar" is.
So, I told her, "Susan Boyle,
I'mma let you finish,
but 'Sisterhood of
the Traveling Pants 2'
is the best movie of the year."
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
You want to know where I was
when I first heard about
"Avatar"?
I was doing a flash mob with
Snooki, JWoww,
and The Situation's cousin,
The Circumstance.
And when we realized
we all forgot to water
our FarmVille crops,
so we drove to my place
in my Nissan Cube
while blasting
the "Glee" soundtrack,
because we're big Gleeks.
And I heard an ad
for "Avatar" on the radio
while Snooki was asking me if I
was Team Edward or Team Jacob.
-Man, 2009 was a different time.
-2009?
Mine was from this morning.
-Hey, guys, I read that
battery-powered planes
are gaining traction
among major airlines.
They're set to be
in the air by 2028.
Yeah, battery-powered planes.
Actually, they've been
around for a while.
In fact, Spirit's entire fleet
runs on four AAA batteries.
It's true.
I heard about
a woman in Washington
who allegedly stole a car
and didn't have
a great getaway plan.
Check this out.
-If you plan to steal a car,
don't drive into
freshly poured concrete.
Lakewood police say
the person who tried to
make it out with this
Mini Cooper did just that.
They got out and tried to run
but were arrested anyway.
Police say the driver was
holding a bottle of whiskey
at the time.
-Yeah, you didn't need to
tell us that last part.
We assumed. Guys, get this.
Under a new law in California,
employers will
soon be banned from screening
employees for marijuana.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. That's right.
Employers will no longer be able
to drug-test people.
But if you ask me, they're still
trying to find ways around it.
Here are some of the questions
that they're asking
on the job application.
First up, it says...
You know what I'm saying?
Next up, it says...
-Okay.
-So I'm thinking...
After that, it says...
Next, it asks...
-Whoa!
-And, finally, it asks...
-Just interesting.
I'm just saying, they're tough.
Guys, did you see this?
Residents of Salt Lake City
have reported
hearing strange music
coming from the sewers.
Yeah, strange music,
as opposed to
the totally normal music usually
heard coming from the sewers.
Finally, a wedding reception
in New Jersey
had to be relocated
after the floor caved in
while people were dancing.
People showed up at the E.R.
like, "Hi.
I'm here for the
Freedman wedding."
Yeah. I'm pretty sure it's the
first wedding with
an open bar and an open floor.
Guys, it seems like there's
so much going on right now.
Former President Trump
is being sued by
New York's attorney general
for fraud.
The United Nations General
Assembly is underway.
This weekend, Disney is
re-releasing the movie "Avatar."
[ Laughter ]
In theaters.
They're re-releasing it.
And the FTA is warning people
against following
a TikTok recipe for
Nyquil chicken.
There's just so much to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
♪♪
First up, Trump.
The attorney general of New York
is suing him
for allegedly lying about
the value of his assets.
Between this,
the January 6th committee,
and the stolen
classified documents,
Trump's got more problems
to deal with than...
the United Nations.
Their big General Assembly
is this week in New York City,
and every hotel, restaurant,
and street is absolutely packed.
But you know what isn't packed?
A movie theater showing
"Avatar."
[ Laughter ]
That movie came out in 2009,
and now it's being re-released.
Nobody really asked for it,
but here it is.
Kind of like...
Nyquil chicken.
People saw the recipe on TikTok,
and now the FTA is saying,
stay away.
It sounds gross, but if you fry
it and throw it in a bucket,
it's perfect for...
Donald Trump.
[ Laughter ]
This latest lawsuit...
[ Applause ]
He's in serious legal trouble,
but honestly,
by now, it kind of
feels like we've...
seen this movie before.
If you forgot, "Avatar" is about
oddly colored creatures
that have fallen on hard times,
which sounds a lot like...
Donny T.
[ Laughter ]
When Trump was interviewed
by state officials,
he pleaded the fifth,
because when it came to
answering questions,
he was too...
chicken.
Come on, guys!
Don't make Nyquil chicken
or Tamiflu turkey
or Robitussin ribs.
That stuff will make you turn...
blue.
Back in '09,
"Avatar" made over $2 billion,
which is also how much...
Trump said
his apartment's worth.
And if you think that's legal,
you must be high on...
sizzurp chicken.
So in conclusion...
nations unite...
losing fight.
Back in blues...
chicken snooze.
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, this is fun.
Earlier tonight,
Elton John performed
on the South Lawn
of the White House.
It was an exciting night
for the Bidens.
The concert started right
after dinner, at 3:00 PM.
[ Laughter ]
Biden hosting Elton John at
the White House makes sense.
There's no better anthem for
a 79-year-old president
than a song called
"I'm Still Standing."
Don't you think?
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw that it's
National Dog Week, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And to celebrate, Tinder is
putting rescue dogs on their app
to match them
with potential owners.
It's exactly the same
as normal Tinder.
Everyone says they enjoy food
and long walks on the beach.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a popular
craft beer in Australia
was recalled over concerns
of "excess alcohol."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the people who
bought it were like,
"We can't recall anything."